what's the matter with San Francisco
what's the matter with California what's
the matter with Democrats in this state
the rank and file don't realize what the
folks they're voting for are doing with
that power it has very little to do with
social justice and everything to do with
protecting special interests who don't
give a rat's ass about the poor
by-and-large
I'm Chris Reid I'm an editorial writer
for the San Diego union-tribune and I
also host a radio show part time on KOCO
600 a.m. in San Diego what's going on in
California is astonishing in that it
represents essentially a repudiation of
democratic ideals the Democrats dominate
the state but they're supposed to be
originally all about social justice or
at least since the New Deal in the 1930s
the Democrats are supposed to be about
protecting the poor people the
downtrodden those who can't help
themselves but on issue after issue the
Democratic Party in California uses its
power in ways that hurt the poor and
hurt the downtrodden especially the
minorities that they supposedly champion
the worst single story to appear last
year in the pages of the Los Angeles
Times had to do with proposal by some
parents in a South Los Angeles district
to set up a charter school they were
really unhappy with their school under
state laws countenance by Democrats
poorer schools almost always end up with
very inexperienced teachers who are
often subject to to turnover and so you
have a discontinuity on the faculty and
you have a you know a not a ripe setting
for education reform there's no Jaime
Escalante at this schools so anyway the
parents proposed setting up a charter
school in South LA and what happens
anonymous leaflets are deposited at the
site where they want to have the meeting
to organize for the charter school that
warns that people who come risk
deportation now nobody knows who did
this but there's only one suspect
members of the United Teachers Los
Angeles nobody else has a motive to try
to sandbag charter schools and nobody
else has such a hatred of charter
schools that they would actually
threaten Latinos that if you're an
illegal immigrant are you sure that this
is something you want to do every summer
sometimes stretching into the fall and
weather times are good or bad the
low-hanging fruit are always cuts in
programs for social services I did some
research on this from 2002 to 2007 this
is a period when revenue in California
was exploding because of the housing
boom probably a 1/3 or more increase in
state revenue over that period the
budget for the state Department of
Social Services which handles child and
family welfare programs aid to the blind
and deaf food stamps and more it went up
from 8.2 billion to nine B about the
rate of inflation meanwhile the budget
for schools up 42% and prisons up 88 %
in other words teachers and prison
guards this is social justice doesn't
look that way to me
another example the Democrats offer of
how they are sticking up for poor
people's interests is perverse it has to
do with their opposition to
implementation of the 1996 federal
welfare reform act California has
something like one-third of the nation's
welfare clients and 1/6 of the
population why because California has
refused to implement welfare reform now
welfare reform is broadly described by
many folks across the spectrum as one of
the great anti-poverty programs of
modern American history because it
really did forced millions of people to
change their lifestyles and actively
seek work so the perverse thing is the
Democrats are bagged are bragging about
sandbagging and anti-poverty program but
it gets even worse than that I have seen
anecdotal evidence that one of the
reasons that they may be opposing
welfare reform or sandbagging it is
because they want to protect government
jobs there used to be a lawmaker from
the San Fernando Valley a very
thoughtful and unusual guy moderate
Republican doctor named Keith Richmond
he didn't fit the cookie quarter mold of
Democrats and Republicans on either side
of the size of this ideological divide
he really believed that government
health care should be made available to
poor people to minorities because it's
there it's budgeted it's just
underutilized it's something like a
third to a half of kids who are eligible
haven't been signing up so he proposed
setting up an online system to register
kids for free California health care
programs and he was told forget about it
because because it could lead to a loss
of jobs at the county offices were folks
register for health care for their kids
you can't make this stuff up the idea
that Walmart is the enemy of poor people
is just bizarre on its face Jason Furman
who is now an economist who works for
President Obama used to work for John
Kerry before that worked for Bill
Clinton in 2005 wrote that Walmart is in
arguably a progressive force because
raising folks standard of living helps
people especially poor people but in San
Diego as in throughout California
Democrats have lined up behind the idea
that cheap groceries are a social evil
what what does that have to do with
social justice keeping people from
making ends meet Walmart a single
does more to help social justice than a
dozen Democratic lawmakers well the
rejection of prop 19 means we're going
to see the continuation of the status
quo of the drug war in California and
once again the social justice question
comes to the fore we've had studies as
recently as a few weeks ago that point
out that minorities use marijuana less
than white folks but are
disproportionately punished doesn't that
suggest to social justice advocates that
the drug war isn't exactly you know
helping the people that they supposedly
care about now in the old days the
notion was well Democrats were a little
better on this issue than Republicans
nowadays there's not a dimes worth of
difference between the two i sat in this
very office grilled Jerry Brown a couple
times about the drug war and he would
have none of it
forty years into the drug war when do we
finally have you know our paradigm shift
our epiphany and acknowledge that it's
been a failure well in California the
Democrats were part of the opposition to
prop 19 they were part of the ones who
said we've got to keep with the status
quo how long does the status quo have to
be a complete flop before you give up on
it
the disconnect between the interests of
environmentalists and the interests of
the working class lower socioeconomic
groups in California is immense for
example the Central Valley we have 40%
unemployment now in parts of the Central
Valley and that's primarily Latino
farmworkers because of what is fairly
described as man-made droughts
environmental rules that prevent water
from getting to farms and yet we have
spectacles like Sacramento congresswoman
Doris Matsui who grew up on these farms
in the Central Valley opposing efforts
to provide emergency relief now is this
social justice to care more about fish
than about humans about the farm workers
I don't think so in San Diego you see
minority business after minority
business smaller and less capitalized
basically either having to shut down
most their operations or to lose a great
portion of their workforce or just to
shut down completely because of airboard
rules meant to cut down on diesel
pollution now this is not social justice
to come up with rules that uniquely
punish
really and uniquely put out of business
the less capitalized firms in effect
it's a sopped a big business by
eliminating their smaller competitors by
having these incredibly onerous and
costly new regulations in California
views itself as the leading edge of
environmentalism in the world and maybe
30 or 40 years ago that made sense when
they're fighting for safer cars but at
this point they're fighting for
environmental rules that only make it
more and more difficult to find jobs in
category after category and the the
progress that's being made on air and
water pollution is marginal it's not the
primary stuff anymore on the margins
they're fighting in ways that hurt
people day after day after day the ab32
is the state's landmark anti-global
warming law passed in 2006 forcing a
switch to cleaner but costlier energy
now apart from the fact that it's crazy
for a single state to go unilaterally
and do what it would take a worldwide
effort to make substantial gains in the
fact is is that this is just an assault
on poor people it's going to force up
the cost of retail energy by 40 to 60
percent and so California which already
has 12 percent unemployment will have a
uniquely uncompetitive business
environment we're already 51st out of 50
states according to the CEOs of America
they also included Washington DC and now
we're going to add on top of that retail
energy costs that are 40 to 60 percent
higher new mandates on businesses that
they have to do a variety of things to
comply with these anti greenhouse gas
goals we may look back on the years of
12% unemployment as the good old days
we're all going to suffer but who's
going to suffer the most who is the
least equipped to deal with an economic
downturn poor folks without savings poor
folks without the educational resources
necessarily to find new jobs this is
social justice it's not my idea of
social justice